[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge
ein hof am see silvia und markus brod
suchen die ruhe in schweden
sie wollen dort ferienwohnungen
vermieten wie warenkorb stefano lott
jonn stefano navarrete zieht es in die
karibik im land liste kilometern sie
ihre chance und familie zogaj möchte
sich in südafrika neu erfinden
ihr traum eine eigene lutz
[Musik]
playa de carmen
auf der baustelle neben der gaza italia
ist überraschend chef fernando
aufgetaucht ihm gehört der baugrund
stefano ist verantwortlich dafür dass
hier alles planmäßig vorangeht den bau
haben die auswanderer gezeigt 14
appartements und zwei ladenlokale
entstehen hier da ist vertrauen gut aber
kontrolle besser
ein vorzimmer von haaren und da hat aber
will er so lange und ich respektiert aus
zu sein etwas ist dies habe die vermisse
aber alles andere
er geht lieber seinen weg in der letzten
folge führte lässt ist der verwalter in
weitere geschäfte des onkels 1
stefano lotti musste zurück das haus in
baselland ist immer noch nicht verkauft
in schweden renovierte markus das kleine
ferienhaus ohne aber die geburt drückt
von tag zu tag näher und annika mussten
in südafrika in die schule
und doris und tiefe entdeckten ihr
traumhaus eine villa mit wahl sicht
[Musik]
noch zwei stunden dann muss der
phänologie das haus in niederdorf in
baselland geräumt haben
stefano hat endlich einen käufer
gefunden nach vielen absagen
das haus gehört er zu ihrer firma die
auswanderer führten eine personalagentur
und der relativ viel interessanter aber
die meisten abschreckt wo sieglos ist
das ist europa und den ahorn erstmal
zurück im hoch ein umfeld geschaffen da
muss dann genau hat magische vorzubeugen
gewalt
[Musik]
jetzt muss der fahrer nur noch zur
mutter im kino
ihr abstand fahren ist klar so ist
die käufer sind nicht irgendwer sondern
zwei alte bekannte der stephanus pascal
und claudio sind mit versicherungen und
hanf läden zu geld gekommen sie
investieren in alles was geld bringt
[Musik]
mit den schweizer kontakten wollen sie
auch in mexiko ihr geschäft ankurbeln
[Musik]
sonntag bei familie talker neu gehört
wachhund emi zur familie
die türkei sind mittlerweile seit acht
monaten in südafrika
die erfüllung ihres traums von einer
eigenen lodge ist immer noch weit
entfernt
zuletzt glaubten sie ein passendes
objekt gefunden zu haben
sie unterzeichneten sogar den vorvertrag
für dieses doppelhaus mit weitsicht und
ist ein grund warum mir einfach dass wir
unser gasthaus im 08 15 eingestellt dass
er so family familie projekt
das haus liegt in einer feriensiedlung
weit weg vom elend der townships
genießen hier reiche gäste südafrikas
naturreichtum wenn sie auf verschiedene
prozess durchgemacht werden
ich meine dieses erste projekte mir
nicht realisiert denn eigentlich den
klima alternativen denkt denkt okay
durch den mieter sollen wir denn noch
informiert dass man einige imame
generieren wir machen häufig sogar auf
und informierte permanent und so und das
ist noch immer so viel es ist immer
darum gegangen dass man sich sagen noch
gar nicht genug tun würde zu gestalten
warten ist es perfekt objekte her und
geld doris mit der konsequenz dass es
halt jetzt noch länger gott bist mir
york rief mal war ich mit dem projekt
aber sich gut
es gehört zu dem prozess es passt die
familie und ihr traumhaus
die türkei wird trauen darauf dass sie
sich irgendwann finden
[Musik]
auf dem hof am see ist das kleine
ferienhaus fertig markus boor renoviert
jetzt die große ferienwohnung seit fünf
wochen schafft er von früh bis spät auf
der baustelle mehrere wände hat markus
versetzt boden wille der erneuert und
alle zimmer neu gestrichen
[Musik]
sie berichtet die vierzimmerwohnung
komplett neu ein
orient ist der erste gast aus der
schweiz
sie sollte eigentlich schon da sein
[Musik]
ein kleinwagen aus basel
das kann nur gut sein
sie ist frisch portioniert und kommt
nicht um hier ferien zu machen
orient unterstützt die beiden für die
nächsten drei monate für freie kost und
logis hilft sie auf dem hof kurz hatten
per anzeige jemanden gesucht der job war
heiß begehrt hat das rennen gemacht
der markt jetzt wirklich das eindruck
macht
das user innerhalb von sieben tagen
stark und macht ja aber setzt sich schön
sich wohlfühlen und hättest du
eigentlich auch profi war noch in das
ist praktisch und darf
[Musik]
der hof am see soll bald auch für zahlen
der gäste parat sein cds zeitplan ist
exakt getaktet
in südafrika versucht tv weitere
kontakte aufzubauen
[Musik]
drei neue kollegen trommelt tibor
zusammen
und hinterher wird afrika sie denn
bereits ab rollte und und ich glaube weg
[Gelächter]
in der villa in stanford wohnen die
türkei ist nun schon ein halbes jahr
obwohl sie eigentlich nur zwei monate
bleiben wollten
zum alltag gehört mittlerweile auch
hannah lee die haushaltshilfe zweimal
die woche kümmert sie sich um das haus
und um die familie aus der schweiz
ok 200 rand verdient sie am tag knapp 15
franken stücke die auch oft vater bist
einfach arbeitsplätze schaffen und wenn
du über erste merkt es ist für die
person enorm wichtig das hat im job in
der pfalz jetzt finde innerhalb der it
manager kein und das ist eine stadt
danzig broterwerb für die ganze familie
oder irgend 40 lebt america waren mit
mir aus gern selber mache einfach wenn
wir so spielen wie im moment
aber sie hat eine mega vielleicht
unterschätzen nach rom
[Musik]
eine halbe stunde hat zur gewartet
schließlich sind zwei von den drei
kollegen aufgetaucht sie hängen plakate
auf für ein herbstfest in stanford
tibor hat sich dem organisationskomitee
angeschlossen
das fest geht es zum ersten mal die
neuen kontakte könnten den poker ist
auch helfen ihren platz und cup zu
finden
runde
das fest soll weiß er aus den
wohlhabenden gebieten mit schwarzem aus
den villenvierteln zusammenbringen
[Musik]
letzter zwischenstopp in der schweiz
dann setzen die auswanderer stefanos
stefanou alles auf die karte der mexiko
leslie ist in die schweiz mit gekommen
sie hat für onkel fernando erarbeitet
und für seine geschäfte kontakte zu den
behörden aufgebaut
seit ein paar monaten sind leslie und
stefano ein paar
die beiden haben sich in mexiko bereits
verlobt
[Musik]
gleich will stefano seinen förderer der
mutter präsentieren
[Musik]
stefano ist einzelkind und bei seiner
mutter groß geworden
[Gelächter]
der auswanderer und seine verlobte das
lässt sich die familie nicht entgehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
stephanus vater ist vorbeigekommen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
deutsche vita und karibische
lebensfreude la familia ist um ein neues
mitglied reicher
[Musik]
[Applaus]
einkaufstour in schweden für die große
ferienwohnung der burg
ich habe sie im leben doch noch letzte
finessen fürs bad erfolglos
[Musik]
das budget ist genau kalkuliert die
auswahl darauf abgestimmt sie haben
baumärkte und möbelhäuser abgeklappert
prospekte gewälzt und das design fertig
schlecht das war ja auch 280 und ist
zwei meter
aber wenn ich es jedoch einfach damit
machen jetzt aber durch im regal und
überrascht
super trader sind sie immer super viel
zusammen entscheiden immer gesetzlichen
einige und mit ihr ist glaube ich das
also wir sind viel später tief gerutscht
inklusive sind exklusiv müssen wir
sprechen die zahlen als 7000 krone darf
man die größte terror prozess sagt sie
möge mit meinen kollegen 58 franken
[Musik]
zurück ins kino zurück an die arbeit
vielmehr kümmert sich jetzt vor allem um
den garten
sie ist hochschwanger und will nichts
mehr riskieren so klimafonds
wintermonaten sich wirklich noch voll
machen
wenn ich so andere frau gehören oder
kollegin von mir wo es war schlimm
ihr mann markus hat noch keinen tag frei
gemacht seit sie ausgewandert sind im
moment schaffte vor zwei
sie würden gern helfe aber es ist halt
so
mir ist mega konferenz im büro macht
wenn das was macht man also dem macho
der muss daheim gar nichts machen die
traum variante ab und sechs wochen
schwer bis jetzt nicht diese art
[Gelächter]
arbeitsteilung in schweden
viel zu tun aber den beiden geht die
arbeit leicht von der hand
[Musik]
mit stacheldraht gesichert die
primarschule des townships in stanford
doris und regina dürfen dort einen raum
benutzen sie bereiten ein transparent
für das herbstfest vor regina ist
deutsche und ebenfalls ausgewandert in
stanford hat sie eine hilfsorganisation
auf die beine gestellt für das
herbstfest wollen sie mit den kindern
aus den townships masken und
dekorationen basteln
als gelernte sozialarbeiterin ist sie es
aus der schweiz gewohnt sich zu
engagieren und genau hinzuschauen und wo
es notwendig ist zu helfen
dann ist es soweit
prinz von bel 35 kinder sind gekommen
[Gelächter]
ein paar stunden raus aus dem harten
alltag der elendsviertel
aus einem alltag voller vernachlässigung
und schlechter ernährung kluwer jung
alle werden morgen wiederkommen zum
herbstfest und zum großen umzug
[Musik]
in liestal läuft rund
stephan hocke nicht die familie macht
jetzt der formalitäten klar und ist
glücklich mit seiner verlobten leslie
die mannschaft hat ja quasi chef dennis
schottler freundschaftlich sehr
sympathisch und so isch d liebi
entstanden
ich bin sehr froh dass ich sie rasiert
man natürlich sehr viel erhalten weil es
sich denn schon mit ganz so einfach aber
fußballer in ein fremdes land und ich
brauche so schrecklich rückhalt kann das
mit ihren gefunden und ich bin nicht
krank von gott also sich wirklich genau
was wo nix zwölfter der letzte schritt
bald kannst du von mexiko seine
geschäfte und investitionen ohne den
onkeln aufgleisen
stephanus zukunft liegt in der karibik
jetzt ist es amtlich die zeit bei mami
ist vorbei stefano lotti hat das haus
der firma verkauft die steuern bezahlt
und seine letzten persönlichen dinge weg
geräumt
heute nacht geht es rund 9000 kilometer
richtung mexiko
12 die tägliche kleine flucht aus dem
elternhaus ein letztes mal
[Musik]
alles parat für das herbstfest morgen
aber nach dem großen umzug gibt es für
die kinder aus den townships nichts zu
essen
die organisatoren haben dafür kein geld
bereitgestellt durchgeführt und das ding
deswegen stoney abfall ist alles weg
match finale wäre ja ich weiß auch die
kinder vom mitgereisten
und wenn du in deutsch nach zwei stunden
laufen ja nicht dass wir schon über
nachher wieder zurücklaufen oder ich
meine sicher dass zumindest eines garten
finanziert und da schon klar ist ja
nicht ich denke dass wir mit dieser
tradition betreffe da sachen finanzen
das ist er also sie das sind alles
mittendrin in diesen extremen
gegensätzen suchen tokens weiter ihren
platz zum leben und arbeiten
[Musik]
post in snuko für markus ein neuer
schwung arbeit die möbel für die große
ferienwohnung kommen an silvia die neue
einrichtung für die vier zimmer wohnung
ausgesucht und online bestellt ein
ecksofa zwei kommoden vier nachttische
und sechs betten alles da der gelernte
schreiner macht sich ans werk
schwedische möbel zusammensetzen siehst
du den mann dort wurde gemacht werden
abgeschreckt und die matratze die mir
hän heißt auch mit logik die heiße hamar
bleibt
letztlich scheiterten aber bisher nicht
verhängt
das kommt mir gefällt was langsam
dämmert es markus na ja ich glaub das
glaubt er hat das bettgestell falsch
montiert ist möglich sagt mir dass ich
so schnell durch und schauen was allen
das ist das dach und wände montageleiter
sanaa
wer ständig und für slawik ich hab mich
einfach für derartige ziele anstatt für
logistik wobei es bei uns so gut
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
also
herbstfest in stanford
[Musik]
der halbe ort ist auf den beinen
jung und alt schwarz und weiß doris und
andere freiwillige laufen mit den
kindern mit
[Musik]
der tross zieht vom township ins zentrum
der umzug ist ein voller erfolg
nach zwei stunden ist die parade vorbei
jetzt haben alle hunger aber die kinder
aus den townships können sich kein essen
kaufen kein bradley keine service kein
mineral das ende der folklore
in südafrika laufen die dinge anders als
in der schweiz
[Musik]
3 uhr 30 am morgen bei familie lotte in
franken drauf sind alle auf den beinen
stephanus vater ist schon parat
er fährt seinen sohn zum flughafen
stunde null
jetzt geht's los jetzt einmal david
ausläuft ich war schon glücklich
[Musik]
das passt das ist gut
der abschied spricht seiner mutter fast
das herz
damit als defa noch nicht gerechnet
[Musik]
nicht so gut zu uns jetzt eher
wahrscheinlich
in vier stunden geht der flieger in die
karibische sonne
[Musik]
ginge es nach mutter anita könnte
stefano jederzeit zurückkommen
[Musik]
sie hat immer einen platz für ihn
weiße strände türkisfarbenes wasser und
die große liebe sich in der karibik
treiben lassen
kann man so sagen können aber für eine
berliner gruppe
[Musik]
energie tanken für die ehrgeizigen
immobilien pläne das gehört jetzt zum
businessplan
[Musik]
in singapur sind die letzten hürden
geschafft die ferienwohnung im farmhaus
ist so gut wie fertig ich bin wirklich
stolz auf das was wir geleistet
das ist wirklich cool gute nacht
erleichterung macht sich breit aber von
amtswegen noch ohne brief und siegel
situation ist so dass man erwarte sind
bisher der grundbucheintrag
abgeschlossen wird
ich warte mehr dritte festival meister
wird
und ja es ist komisch dass ihr vater
wieder machen
fast ihre gesamten ersparnisse stecken
mittlerweile in dem hof knapp 50000
franken haben sie ausgegeben
trotz aller planung gab es die eine oder
andere unvorhergesehene investition ein
rasenmäher natürlich ein aufsetzer mit
allradantrieb
ohne vier mal vier ging es nicht
die steigungen auf dem gelände bohlen
bezwungen werden
[Musik]
rasenpflege für markus bekommt sie ihn
spielen eine ganz neue dimension
[Musik]
am anderen ende der welt besichtigen die
talker ist einmal mehr ein haus das
grundstück liegt am rande eines kleinen
dorfes rund 50 kilometer von ihrem
bisherigen zuhause entfernt
es umfasst ein wohnhaus und ein
nebengebäude in dem sich vier
gästezimmer befinden
[Musik]
der traum von einer eigenen lutz ließ
sich hier verwirklichen
[Musik]
rund 425.000 franken kostet das neue
daheim eine summe die familie focker
gerade noch alleine stellen könnte
ich finds uno erstmals wieder oliver
hein der oper begeistert dass auch leben
ihres tanzes vom eigenen hust arena wo
sich wirklich für familie zogaj scheint
diesmal tatsächlich alles zu stimmen
wenn der verkauf schnell über die bühne
geht könnten sie pünktlich zur neuen
saison eröffnen
[Musik]
nächste woche bei auf und davon neue
ideen in mexiko die beiden stefano
suchen sich einen neuen geschäftspartner
zusammen schaffte zum geldmachen mit dem
cinema familie zogaj zieht ins neue heim
und erlebt dort eine böse überraschung
in schweden geht die arbeit weiter
schilf mehren anstatt
geburtsvorbereitung ich hab ne woche
eher bücher gelesen was tapezier und
natürlich noch das kind wirklich sollte
doch das baby kommt früher als erwartet
wichtige lücke mit alkohol träumen
[Musik]
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge